salut à tous c'est pêcheurs de trésors
aujourd'hui en accompagné d'Alex et de
sa petite famille et on va pêcher sous
un pont on va c'est un pont en piéton il
y aura peut-être pas grand chose mais
des fois il y a quand même des petites
surprises
intéressantes je crois que j'ai quelque
chose
première trouvaille
qui a du poids oh une poussette
ah non il est pas dommage hop
franchement c'est ouf en bon état comme
ça mais ça vaut au moins 50 euros non
allez vas-y qu'est-ce que tu nous sors
de beau
on dirait
cela ça fait un moment qu'elle est dans
l'eau
bravo
ah c'est un tube avec ce qui va nous
faire une montre
en plus tu vois elle s'est cassée donc
elle est tombée du poignet
c'est la température
ça va franchement je pense que tu peux y
aller faire changer le bracelet combien
ça doit coûter ça va pas être cher hein
pour le coup je te confirme que les
résidents
pour montrer où c'est
il y a un objet de forme
il a plutôt gros mais il accroche pas
bien
donc on va voir
ça glisse
ça va mieux
je te la détends parce que sinon tu vas
pas tirer sur maison
ça va
se faire manger par une belle féroce
on va essayer de le remettre
en plastique que j'ai passé
[Musique]
j'ai fait un nœud
alors petit naturiste tu penses qu'on a
quoi bah pour l'instant on va utiliser
le travail parce que c'est trop lourd et
c'est enfoncé franchement c'est bizarre
j'ai jamais vu un truc comme ça non
aucune idée
moi je pense à une petite barque un
petit bar on a pas tendu avant
il y a des trucs à l'intérieur donc
une sacrée quantité
S
j'entends les gars c'est pas fini
c'est pas fini
bon allez je vais tenter de traverser le
pont par dessus
c'est un seul solution non en fait ça ne
sert à rien pour la vidéo mais bon
en vrai ça fait peur
c'est mal parti
et la petite fourchette
ne mangez pas les fourchettes on vous
rappelle que c'est l'aliment qu'il faut
vendre
on est obligé de trouillé à chaque fois
c'est une grosse galère donc pour
aujourd'hui on va arrêter et en plus il
fait super chaud donc je vais découper
le morceau qu'on a déjà sorti et on
reviendra récupérer le reste dans une
autre vidéo si vous voulez dites le moi
en commentaire et on se dit à la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle vidéo de
pêche à l'aimant
par contre
c'est pas drôle
c'était très limite c'est une bonne
expérience franchement j'ai adoré